弾み雪をて石原さとみに似てませんか多分
に出ないですこんにちははじめ社長です
というわけで
もう
はだけできた正直をばらけてきたような
ことが起きますタワー3県のうちに関する
お話でございますが皆さんもちろん実家に
住んでいるお家に住んでる方も
いらっしゃいますし賃貸その書いてるうち
に住んでいる方もいらっしゃると思うん
ですけどその電気代等がが集い都下水道代
ってあると思うんですけどもどんなもの
ですか雑貨にどんな持って聞いてもなんか
まあ高い人でもわかんないですよ大津な
サイズとか住んでいる人の数にもよるん
ですけど多分一人暮らしだったらに
3000円で済む方もいらっしゃいますし
一人暮らしでも高くてもなんか5千円から
1万円くらいかなは辛いよ一般的な風邪な
人が天気だ糸数伊藤園の値段のちょっと
アベレージ平均は分からないんですけども
おそらく月だでも5万とかはなんか
よっぽど変なことしなきゃいけないのかな
と思ってるんですけれども今回このいえ
この3県のうちのダサいが先月やばすぎた
もういいんんしカリブに涙持ってえっ
ビックリしすぎて意味が分からんっていう
値段なのでちょっと動画にしてますねか何
かこれ多分ねー普通の人聞いたら引きます
よ選挙どうぞトーマスんですけどもじゃあ
まず12月12月のガス台の合計が
21,900円21,900円ですまあ
これでも待った解放でしょうかサイトした
でもまぁなんかそんなもんかなとも思い
ますこのうち大きいし債務作る動画あった
んですけど結構お湯を使ったりしてたんで
かなりの量大きく1000万円に向け違っ
て頑張ってた時期タンデマー2万円
ちょっと高いけどまぁいっかと思いました
次1月10月が
11万7000円手を洗います
あれ2万円ぐらいじゃなかった気に3万
あれっ
チャンネル救出だったんだよチャンネル9
失点だからこの家でのんびり過ごすことも
多かったからうわぁ結構飛んだけどまでも
東京行く回数も減って静岡に聞こえたから
まあ高くなるでもうさすがにちょっと
12万ってどうなんだろうと思って2月2
月のガス料金約
1万円です
なんでなんでやなぜ素材変化指がわかる
ニス10000
大学生の新卒大学生の初任給でも払えんぞ
2100004
怖い怖いという感じのが出てきますみて
くださいまあ2種類が好きてるんですけど
も一般形とを出すと ghp ようって
いう a 今とかぬかすなんかなちょうど
これも甘くらしくないとわからないんです
けども先月がこれでまず1万と6000万
12万ぐらいで2月はこれですよね
195800傷2月ま6セント
一番3000円で合計で混ぜてちょうど
201万円くらいなんですよ
[音楽]
越冬えっとですね
このながらが集いってこんなものかな2月
の俺の生活見返すとそんなに月何が使った
なとも思ってないんですよで12月1月も
正直その生活変わってないしおうちが広
すぎてあの一部だやこのずっとつけっぱ
なしにしてるんですけどもそれでも
21万円とか e 9わけないんだと思っ
てけっこぴっくりしてますちょっと金に
やってみましょう
大丈夫
はいはいはいどうもどうもこんにちははい
はいこれは何ですかこれですね血球合計2
月がこの前機と21万と k これを暑
そういうことなりますね
おっ
浴感が使えましたん
してないいうかー
これは分からせ
なんでこんな高くなってるのかっていう
わからないとして大きいたてもって普通
そんなものの岩盤に十何万名前基本ここっ
て一般の家庭というよりかは完全にビル
みたいなんだそうですね彼がちなんで
ビルーのガスが一夫平均がいくらかわかん
ないけど思います私だね俺たちの知らない
そうなので何かそういった4プラになって
可能性もあるし
ただそもそもマーガスの空調停
じゃましょうねそれかなっていう牙するん
だけどただ
その先月とかさズーク作りが使い無線か
はい普通に月やすいのはわかるんだけど
1月と比べても泣かん
20竜宮みたいななんかこれが凄すぎるよ
ねだした強いするかもいやあのバクゥ結構
震えてますよこれ人一人雇ってるような
もんかねやっぱちょっとこれやばいんこれ
ちょっと調べないといけないなそう底の
いいねそのガスどこで使ってるんだろう
ちょっと見てみまーなんかみましょう
軽い軽い軽い
ちょっとちょっと俺もどこで何がが使われ
てるかわかんないけど皆さんあそうだね
この部屋は遥かそういうえっと一応これね
これほぼこれが一応ガス空調なんだけど1
回に関しては壊れてジェットでこれで全部
入ったをやるそうだねっ
[笑い]
青系の色ずっとこうしますからしっかり
出せば暖房がないかは今壊れてて高校てん
じゃないんでないですねが[ __ ]なんですね
一般家庭にガスの空調を使っている人現場
でいます
ここでもついありますよ1回は東大寺ない
はい1階ですねはい
はい魔石鉱原因ナビ気がするぞこの部屋も
必要
ずっと暖房がついてるんですよねただ寒い
よねこのキャ寒いんじゃ広さがあるから
beauty そんな姉なんか云々
サーカスでてることないと思うん
いや絶対に沿った続けて21番いかんよ
確かにね
新月比べてもいやもう
考えられるねほんと踊ろう号にさーんっを
使っているかなあんちゃんメイド結構あり
そう考えてございますあやしいなとこで
ローだねここだねぇ
考えますとこれはずっとついている一番
そうここがこれよねそうだねそこの
スイッチのある場合これこれこれこれだけ
はあー
気骨でパスにしているというか34回の
あった方をこれ何サボってることで肌じゃ
ないときて上に行くから3年4でこれを
まとめて100パンたと言ってる感じも
このレールよちょっとほ突起これ
こんなもい
これで21万さすがにちょっと無理あると
思うけどもっとなかろうかああああそう
なんか引いたんでちょっとばから今日
突付けばでもなかっいって文字3万人に
行きません
違う気がするなぁ
本当でもそれぐらいしないと付録だよねー
なちゅらー
からんすよでも普通ではない子ってあるよ
ねうーん
ガス漏れは
そ漏れのそれもワンチャンありそうでは
ないんだって
またこのホームですねふーん
まあ完璧にガスが使えるって言ってもが
その旧道期を支えたとかダサに使えますよ
という状態で今その
手直しっていうか交換する
準備してもらってるっていう段階なんで
のは行っしそれこの聖なるなぁカスだて
ジャブのだってっ
塗りを俺じゃなきゃないってたよ伊豆一番
でしょまず人一人雇えるぐらいのお金がを
取っから漏れ出た可能性でちょっとあの僕
書籍を履かせたら女ばかりかれないので第
1区仁保ばの12しておりますのではい
大地くんの仕事はこの謎を解くことです
わかりましたちょっと本来月こんなこられ
たらほんとにもう大
やだこのいいの細かい事とか浦野こういう
ことがありませんとかっていうのは第二巻
朝の国か西2ちゃんねるてる作ったんで
あと大丈夫原因わかったかそのそんな
チャンネルに出すと言ってちょっと分かり
ました
こちらを見て下さいお願いしますそうと
ゆるい
装置とかも知れませんしてます授けと姫
いや21万やばいっ
以上ですはい
さあイン
[音楽]
dl
うっ